mide 102 metros y tiene 22 pisos cuesta
creer que durante cinco años fue el
rascacielos más alto de latinoamérica
su escalar en forma de caracol es una
joya arquitectónica protegida por el
instituto de patrimonio nacional aquí es
un espacio muy grande cada piso es como
una empresa cerrado desde hace una
década este inmueble se ha convertido en
una carga financiera para el gobierno
federal que ha decidido venderlo
la subasta se hará online cualquier
persona física o jurídica puede
participar por su localización ofrece un
amplio abanico de posibilidades oficinas
pisos residenciales o incluso un hotel
durante años este edificio fue el templo
de la música brasileña desde sus
estudios radio nacional lanzó a la fama
a muchos cantantes
aquí también nació la radionovela que
más tarde se transformaría en telenovela
y claro la fiebre del fútbol que se
alimentó gracias a las retransmisiones
en directo
el edificio a no ir es el resumen de
brasil porque representa el brasil
moderno y el brasil que fue construido a
través de las ondas de radio radio
nacional es responsable de que en el
país se hable portugués este espacio
influenció la forma en que los
brasileños consumen los medios de
comunicación tanto la radio como la
televisión
este edificio modernista es obra del
arquitecto francés joseph y sig que
también proyectó el famoso hotel
copacabana palace la subasta marca un
cambio de mentalidad en la era de
bolsonaro esto es un edificio que nos
cuesta 300 mil reales al mes estando
vacío y en decadencia y yo creo que todo
patrimonio histórico tiene que ser
integrado a las fuerzas de la sociedad a
la industria creativa a la iniciativa
privada el comprador tendrá que
restaurar este mini rascacielos situado
en frente del museo del mañana del
arquitecto español santiago calatrava